I've been
dreaming every night
The same dream.
every morning
the same
nightmare
strange
the fate of the multiverse
depends on us
careful stephen this path exacts a heavy toll
okay...
hey everyone we're very excited to
announce that tickets are on sale for
marvel studios doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
get ready for a mind-bending
journey through the multiverse
we're talking infinite impossibilities things
just got out of hand and infinite realities
get your tickets now from marvel
studios doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness only in theaters may 6th
Welcome back everyone marvel just dropped
a brand new doctor strange 2 trailer video
with a bunch of new footage we'll break it
all down it confirmed a bunch of theories
that we had in the previous trailers too
so we'll do a giveaway for imax tickets
for the movie all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your theories
from the trailer on the video obviously
the big thing here is them revealing
billy and tommy it's the same actors that play
billy and tommy during wandavision wiccan and
speed we all thought that they were gonna be in
the movie we saw their toys in this alternate
version of westview in the previous trailers
but this trailer actually presents the footage
of them in a slightly different way than that
previous trailer so they opened the trailer and
both doctor strange and scarlet witch are talking
about having the same dream the same nightmare
every single night now they're kind of talking
about nightmares but they use the dream song
like is it a dream or is it a nightmare for mcu
scarlet witch she talks about it being a nightmare
because she doesn't have billy and tommy she
doesn't have vision so it's her talking more about
her trauma it kind of informs why she goes so far
off the rails and why she's doing what she's doing
with chaos magic in the dark hold and trying to
get a hold of america's shabbos to get across the
multiverse to find a version of billy and tommy so
even if you don't agree with what she's doing and
doctor strange probably will not like please don't
do this wanda this is bad you at least sympathize
with why she's doing it but what i think is going
on in this brand new trailer with the footage of
billy and tommy is that when she talks about
it being a nightmare it sort of juxtaposes the
voice over dialogue with a version of her just
wearing plain clothes kind of dropping to her
knees and then grabbing hold of both of them i
think that this is actually a nightmare or the
dream that the mcu scarlet witch is having
this isn't happening in real life the same
nightmare in the previous trailer you see a
version of another scarlet witch grabbing hold
of mcu scarlet witch's face as she falls on the
ground and is crying like there's actually two
of them in this scene so i think that footage in
the other trailer is a completely different scene
of this one of her falling to her knees grabbing
actual billy and tommy that we see because later
in the trailer you also see that alternate version
of scarlet witch in the plane clothes just go
completely nuts she doesn't look exactly like a
zombie but she kind of looks like she's either
being controlled or she's just completely lost it
and is going to kill every single person that she
finds in this multiverse illuminati base the look
on her face just seems kind of haunted as she's
coming for america's shabbos so it's not totally
clear if the variant goes off the rails on her own
or if she's being controlled somehow by the chaos
magic and the darkhold from mcu scarlet witch
we see a little more footage of america chavez
wong and doctor strange fighting on the street
with that version of gargantos or shuma gorath
whatever you want to call him he looks a little
bit more like shuma gorath but i think because
of copyright ip reasons they have to call him
something different gargantos is kind of like
a really small one-off obscure villain from the
name or comics that they never really use that
much so i think they're just using his name for
this version of shuma gorath just for copyright
reasons technically the shuma gorath name actually
originated in the conan comics and the hyborian
age ip and marvel doesn't have access to that
right now there's a lot of weird crossover with
old school doctor strange stuff really deep cuts
and old school conan stuff if you're a long time
comic book reader you probably know what i'm
talking about but part of the idea with billy and
tommy in the movie is that obviously like i said
scarlet witch is looking for a version of them my
early theory right now though is that as off the
rails as she will go during the movie something is
going to have to bring her back from the complete
edge of darkness like they don't want to throw
her under the bus kevin feige said that she's a
really big deal during marvel phase 4 and marvel
phase 5. i think part of the idea during the
movie early theory is that it'll be this alternate
version of billy and tommy if it is an alternate
version maybe it's the original version in some
twisty kind of way but they'll probably be the
ones to save rmcu scarlet witch from herself
so to speak but if it wasn't clear what's
actually going on here i believe america chavez
actually enters the story because she's already
in the process of being chased by this giant
schumacherth looking creature and that's how
she winds up crossing paths with our version of
doctor strange and wong and looks to them for help
one of the weird things that marvel is doing in
this movie is the way that they present the idea
the multiverse and traveling physically between
different dimensions even though we've seen the
avengers travel all over the timeline we just
saw the loki series we saw a bunch of different
timelines a bunch of different kangs from a
bunch of fully alternate universes remember
if a timeline grows to be big enough with enough
branches it becomes a fully alternate universe
we also saw mcu doctor strange go on a magical
tour of the multiverse during the first movie
technically he was traveling across different
dimensions though the important distinction is
that when you travel across different universes
your physical body doesn't really change that much
it's like each dimension has their own multiverse
so when you travel between universes inside the
regular third dimension where we all exist things
are relatively similar but when you travel across
different dimensions your fundamental reality like
the way you exist changes like in the trailer it
looks like america chavez also takes them across
different dimensions because they travel to an
animated universe which is vastly different
from the normal reality they also travel across
what looks like this block based dimension where
they kind of turn into block forms of themselves
the way marvel is explaining this after the events
of spider man no way home is that doctor strange
still does not fully understand how to physically
travel between different universes like he
couldn't just open a portal to the other universe
where tobey maguire or where andrew garfield
spider-man lives that's kind of where america
chavez and the darkhold come in i believe the
spell that he's weaving with the darkhold like
it looks like he's weaving chaos magic because
he's using the darkhold because previously we only
thought the scarlet witch could do that is there
some sort of forbidden spell in the dark hole
that he uses to try and fix things to prevent the
multi first from going crazy but it only winds up
making things worse the way they explain america
chavez's character if you know her powers she's
basically able to punch holes through different
dimensions different universes like it's no big
deal as if it's kind of like a mutant ability
the way the marvel explains it right now in the
mcu most of the other characters cannot do that
like mcu scarlet witch as powerful as she is
with chaos magic still needs america chavez to
physically be able to travel between one universe
and another to go find that version of billy and
tommy we see a little more footage of defender
strange in a couple different scenes before he
turns into a zombie or a marvel zombie however
you want to think about him it looks like he's
crashing through one of america chavez's portals
while she's busy being manipulated by this giant
creature that looks like it's being controlled
by chaos magic there's one of scarlet witch that
looks like she's fighting with the team like she's
fighting with wong they turn to face something
and there's these two giant monsters behind them
that look like they're from the dark hold or from
the temple being controlled by chaos magic
somehow all the markings inside this temple
over the walls are the same markings that are on
the dark hold so it just seems like some sort of
locus of power that scarlet witch takes them to
so that she can use the dark hold power here to
travel between different dimensions but then
during a different part of the trailer there's
this other shot of scarlet witch turning around
like she's got black around her eye she's got
black on her fingertips the way you would see
on act at the harkness which usually means that
she's been doing something really really bad so
if you saw the last trailer the funny thing that
they did is they were very misleading they made it
seem like doctor strange was recruiting her to be
part of their new avengers team like ah it'll go
a long way to getting you back on the lunch box
when this trailer seems way more honest about
what she's doing like i have this nightmare
every single night things are going off the
rails and it shows a bunch of footage of her
just having these nightmares of billy and tommy
whereas the last trailer made her seem like more
of a good character they were kind of trying
to hide all this crazy scarlet witch stuff
in this ultron robot variant running through
the room like the other variant of scarlet
witch has already started to go ham on the entire
multiverse illuminati base that's what that whole
big fight with that variant of captain marvel
is the maria rambeau captain marvel variant and
when it seems like she goes supernova here this
actually seems like this scarlet witch variant
just getting ready to completely destroy the
base with this giant eruption of chaos magic
so rip multiverse illuminati everyone pour one out
for them then probably the other biggest reveal of
this new trailer is rmcu doctor strange fighting
the sinister strange variant who full-on grows a
third eye in his forehead as they go at each other
sam raimi and the producers did explain that he's
meant to be kind of like the version of doctor
strange supreme from what if but he's not meant
to be the exact same version it was a little bit
confusing about that when the earlier trailers
dropped they said that they hoped their version
was up to the same task as the original one from
what if so it's a similar type of backstory
like he probably tried to save his reality
then just crossed way too many lines and got way
too powerful and went way too dark in the process
if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments there'll
be at least one or two more trailers before the
movie gets here i just posted my full moon night
episode 2 video in easter eggs you can click here
to watch that and click here to learn all about
superior iron man in the doctor strange 2 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!